[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
détention à paris à l'issue de la
manifestation contre la loi sécurité
globale des protestations partout en
france contre l'article 24 du texte qui
pénalise la diffusion des images de
policiers dans l'intention de leur nuire
les journalistes y voient un risque d'
entrave à leur mission d'information en
créant un nouveau délit dans la loi de
1881 sur la liberté de la presse
[Musique]
la réouverture des commerces en france
autour du 1er décembre confirmation de
jean castex matin le premier ministre ne
donne pas de date précise c'est le chef
de l'état qui doit s'adresser aux
français
alors que la baisse des contaminations
se confirme les sénateurs de la droite
et du centre demandent le retour de la
pratique des sports individuels en plein
air le retour de blaise compaore au
centre de l'élection présidentielle au
burkina faso demain les électeurs de
dire un chef de l'état et les députés de
l'assemblée nationale
la plupart des partis de l'opposition
sont favorables au retour de l'ancien
président toujours en exil en côte
d'ivoire des élections qui pourrait être
entravée sur une partie du territoire à
cause de l'insécurité liée au terrorisme
islamiste
m
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi ces
manifestations aujourd'hui en france
entre l'article 24 de la loi sécurité
globale elle a été adopté hier en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
à paris des syndicats des journalistes
et des collectifs de défense des droits
de l'homme mais aussi des gilet jaune
qui ont protesté place du trocadéro et
il y avait eu vous le voyez quelques
tensions en fin d'après midi les forces
de l'ordre ont dû faire usage de canons
à eau
on va faire le point sur place avec
notre reporter nadège abderrazak bonsoir
nadège vous avez suivi cette
manifestation à paris qu en est il
actuellement
à écouter à magali la manifestation est
terminée les forces de l'ordre ont
procédé à la dispersion en plus beaucoup
de monde derrière nous beaucoup de
journalistes encore mais plus vraiment
de manifestants peut-être cinq ou six
encore présents sur cette place du
trocadéro mais il était cet après midi
plusieurs milliers de personnes s'être
rassemblés ici place du trocadéro pour
dire non donc à cette loi sécurité
globale avec son article 24 un trait est
décriée par les syndicats de
journalistes par les organisations des
droits de l'homme
donc un article 24 on le rappelle qui
punit de 45000 euros d'amendé d'un an de
prison toute diffusion dans un but
malveillant des forces de l'ordre donc
voilà une loi et qui a été examinée
depuis mardi à l'assemblée nationale et
l'article 24 a été adopté hier en
première lecture dans l'hémicycle donc
voilà une manifestation qui a dégénéré à
aux alentours de 17h au coucher du
soleil quand et bien une plusieurs
dizaines d'individus ont commencé à
jeter des projectiles sur les forces de
l'ordre à des forces de l'ordre qui ont
attendu avant de répondre à ces
offensives et puis qui ont dû donc
finalement faire usage de canons à eau
donc que je vous propose d'écouter avec
quelques témoignages de manifestants qui
jugent justement cette loi sécurité
globale liberticide
cette loi ne me plaît pas beaucoup voilà
on est dans une loi liberticide 1p
équipe qui tourne à l'autoritarisme et
je suis s'est désolé d'être dans une
dictature aujourd'hui
et là je vois une police politique qui a
pour probablement pour ordre aujourd'hui
d'avoir l'air gentille pour justifier de
cette loi liberticide qui a été votée
cette nuit
ben c'est une loi qui me fait penser à
la police de la pensée dans orwell 1984
et j'ai pas envie que ça arrive ici j'ai
pas envie que mon gamin qui grandit dans
un
1 j'ai pas envie qu'ils grandissent dans
un système comme ça dans un régime
politique comme ça c'est pour ça qu'il a
une vraie prise de conscience nous
reprise conscience mais c'est à
l'échelle de la terre ce niveau de tous
les pays de toutes les villes que c'est
en train de se soulever parce que parce
qu'on en a marre de cette de cette
dictature mondiale finalement parce que
quand on réfléchit bien et qu'on
rassemble tous les morceaux
si on fait les causes les conséquences
de chaque problème on en revient
toujours au même endroit
et ça c'est insupportable il était
beaucoup beaucoup de journalistes réunis
cet après midi sur cette place du
trocadéro alors leur colère a augmenté
mercredi après les propos de gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur qui
invitait les journalistes à se
rapprocher des autorités avant de
couvrir une manifestation plusieurs une
quarantaine de responsables de rédaction
nationale et ont signé une tribune hier
sur le site du monde pour protester
contre ces propos de gérald darmanin ils
ont dénoncé une atteinte flagrante à la
liberté d'informer et la liberté est de
la presse ils se sont engagés à ne l'a
crédité aucun de leurs journalistes à
l'avenir donc voilà rien ne va plus
entre la presse et le pouvoir la presse
qui est syndicat de la presse qui est
bien ont prévu de nouvelles
mobilisations à partir de la semaine
prochaine
merci beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions on a déjà des razak en direct
de la place du trocadéro à paris
des journalistes malmenés au cours de
cette manifestation à paris c'est le cas
notamment dans un rédacteur du site
internet média tv vous voyez un policier
le fait tomber à terre une personne
tente de lui venir en aide et en prend
également pour son grade sans mauvais
jeu de mots son témoignage a été postée
sur les réseaux sociaux
le matériel professionnel du journaliste
a été détériorée à cause de sa chute
passant que non plus vous le voyez pour
notre journaliste web myriem l'arrivée
qui n'a pas pu continuer à filmer cette
interpellation dans la rue écoutez je
circulais cdc vous ce que les panneaux
et 30 secondes vous êtes à terme et les
fois qu'on commence plus amples
précisions de notre journaliste meriem
lé ribi justement qui revient sur cet
épisode gp donc à la manif l'exception
tutelle à la fin de la de rassemblement
les policiers étaient en train de
charger ils étaient très nombreux et
donc j'ai assisté à cette interpellation
de trois personnes il me semble donc je
revois les images mais je crois que
trois personnes dont une jeune fille sur
la place des droits de l'homme
donc les trois personnes que j'ai filmé
ne posait pas de résistance et crier
qu'ils avaient mal et l'interpellation
comme on peut le voir sur les images est
assez musclé ensuite ils ont été
menottés et emmenés donc sur une avenue
qui au d'abord de la place des droits de
l'homme et la moi j'ai continué à
regarder la scène j'avais mon brassard
de presse en ésident et un moment donné
la jeune fille était palper donc comme
non comme comme on peut le voir au
niveau des chevilles moi j'ai filmé
moment là et donc des politiques nous
ont dirigés vers moi et m'ont demandé de
circuler et de quitter les lieux dans
les 30 secondes
il mange de jade m me faire interpeller
j'ai protesté parce que je leur ai dit
que j'avais le droit de filmer que
j'étais journaliste que j'avais ma carte
de 13 et
ils m'ont dit assez fermement vous
pouvez le voir sur les images de
circuler voilà et donc je me suis
éloigné j'ai continué à regarder la tène
de loin à 50 mètres environ et et j'ai
attendu la gêne qui était assise sur le
trottoir les mains derrière le dos avec
ses camarades que je voyais pas et
ensuite ils ont été emmenés vers un
camion est donc vue parmi les ai perdus
de vue j'ai pas j'ai quitté des yeux et
voyez ce que 10 de ces manifestations
eric verhaeghe il est fondateur du
courrier des stratèges on peut constater
que depuis plusieurs semaines la
polémique sur cette loi ne désenfle pas
ne diminue pas au contraire elle ne fait
que que progresser et ce qui est très
frappant mon point de vue c'est qu'elle
touche des partis au fond très
différente de la population c'est-à-dire
qu'on voit qu'il ya pas mal de
mouvements de gauche qui sont présents
sur cette manifestation mais le rejet de
la loi touche une population beaucoup
plus large que les mouvements politiques
actifs à gauche
elle touche aussi des fractions très
libérale de l'opinion beaucoup plus à
droite
et de ce point de vue on voit bien qu'il
ya quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
que de l'ordre de l'activisme politique
si vous voulez on sent que cette loi est
en train de de toucher aux tréfonds du
pays et qu'elle est en train d'agiter de
nourrir des craintes des mobilisations
également en province dans la plupart
des grandes villes de france films et
des policiers en risquant un an de
prison et une amende de 45000 euros
c'est du foutage de gueule ont fait
valoir les manifestants pour l'article
24 laisse trop de place à
l'interprétation et menace la liberté de
la presse
écoutez on c'est une atteinte grave au
droit de manifester c'est une atteinte
grave à la liberté d'informer et je suis
d'autant plus scandalisé qu'il y a deux
semaines le président de la république
lui-même avec des trémolos dans la voix
défendez la liberté d'expression pour
venir la foulée aux pieds
à peine quinze jours après enfin
l'hypocrisie est totale les attributions
qui vont être beaucoup plus convergentes
entre la police nationale et police
municipale et les forces de sécurité
privée pour moi il s'agit d'une l'ip
lait ni moins qu'une forme de
privatisation de la fonction régalienne
de maintien de l'ordre qui est là aussi
extrêmement grave et voyez à présent ce
qu'en dit notre éditorialiste à luc
themelin on voit bien que derrière cette
loi de sécurité global au delà de des
articles discuter 24 etc
il y a la volonté du gouvernement de
préparer finalement la répression à
venir parce qu'ils savent que 2021 va
être extrêmement délicat difficile avec
un nombre de faillites inégalée avec une
morosité économique qui risque de d'être
là dans la durée et plutôt que de
répondre par dz par le dialogue
eh bien on va simplement un visibiliser
les actions des forces de l'ordre
préparer cette répression d'une façon ou
d'une autre et c'est extrêmement
inquiétant et on a vu d'abord c'était
les journalistes militants qui étaient
visés comme le disait abu hafs et plus
récemment c'est devenu les journées
semaine stream avec cette déclaration
incroyable d'un ministre de l'intérieur
qui était persuadé qu'il fallait que les
journalistes s'inscrivent en préfecture
pour avoir le droit de couvrir des
manifestations cela qui va à l'encontre
de l'état de droit qui va à l'encontre
de la loi sur la liberté de la presse de
1881 il est revenu sur ses déclarations
aujourd'hui
gérald darmanin mais sans créer plus des
mois que cela donc on voit bien que ce
gouvernement est prêt à toutes les
contorsions des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen pour arriver à ses fins
contraindre opprimés et faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas de contestation
visible
on fait le point sur la situation
sanitaire en france à présent avec une
baisse de tous les indicateurs au bout
de deux semaines de confinement 22 1882
nouveaux cas de contamination dépister
ces dernières 24 heures 386 décès
supplémentaires à l'hôpital et un taux
de positivité des tests de 15% ce matin
le premier ministre a confirmé que les
commerces dits non essentiels pourront
rouvrir autour du 1er décembre
jean castex n'a pas donné plus de
précisions sur la date le chef de l'état
qui doit s'adresser aux français un
mardi prochain le fera sans doute
et alors que la baisse des
contaminations se confirme les sénateurs
de la droite et du centre ont demandé
dans une lettre adressée à matignon le
retour de la pratique des sports
individuels en plein air et l'extension
de la limitation d'un kilomètre autour
du domicile pour en parler nous sommes
avec sébastien meurant sénateurs les
républicains du val d'oise
bonsoir sébastien meurant merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france on a
entendu le premier ministre ce matin qui
confirme que a priori à partir du 1er
décembre les commerces dits non
essentiels pourront rouvrir
est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
vous c'est une excellente nouvelle juste
avant noël
il faut absolument que l'activité
économique puis ce redémarrer et que les
petits commerçants que les activités des
plus petits d'entre nous puisse
redémarrer
ça n'a aucun sens de laisser ouvertes
des grandes surfaces sont les petits
commerçants soient ouverts bien sûr
alors vous je ne sais si vous faites
partie de ces sénateurs qui veulent
justement que le sport qui est interdit
au delà d'un kilomètre de son domicile
pour l'instant à cause du confinement
vous voulez que le sport individuel les
sports individuels 1 soit de nouveau
autorisée un peu plus loin que qu'un
kilomètre mais bien sûr évidemment donc
j'étais cosignataires de cette de cette
lettre d'ailleurs c'est très cette règle
n'a pas eu de sens puisque le ministre
de l'intérieur lui-même chargé de faire
appliquer cette règle ne l'a pas ne l'a
pas suivi vous imaginez bien que lorsque
vous faites ça soit du vélo soudas
course à pied ce qui est mon cas en
forêt de moments aussi
on ne respecte pas nous mêmes non plus
de cette règle ça n'a aucun sens et une
pareille le score même en période de
cause
dehors et est bon pour la santé et on
relève aussi les incohérences pour les
jeunes enfants puisque en-deça de 18 ans
le sport à l'école est autorisé et au
delà par contre de 18 ans c'est pas
possible donc pour l'heure deux branlées
redoublant au lycée
encore une mesure qui n'a pas de sens
évidemment et cette règle d'un kilomètre
qu'il faut l'assouplir
il faut redonner de la liberté la
liberté aux français tout simplement
qu'ils sont privés de faire du sport de
l'anah kilomètres qu'ils sont privés de
liberté de travailler donc là c'est elle
qui est en liberté y compris pour le
sport est fondamentale et on le voit
justement et on a entendu effectivement
olivier et rend cette semaine
s'inquiéter des répercussions
psychologiques sur les français à cause
de ce 2e confinement on n'en avait pas
tenu compte pour le premier et les
indicateurs sont assez inquiétants
notamment pour les jeunes
vous pensez qu'il faut donc revoir les
modalités d'un confinement s'il devait
être rétablie à l'avenir mais ce
confinement est une catastrophe
cette gestion de crise par le
gouvernement c'est une humiliation pour
la france ce pays qui avait le meilleur
système de santé au monde
début 2000 n'a pas été capable de
fournir des masques à sa population des
tests a géré par un confinement digne du
moyen-âge en enfermant tout le monde
avec des positions qui ont varié et
monsieur vers en exemple le titre mais
si vous reprenez tout ce qu'il a pu
déclarer et toutes les contradictions
depuis le début de l'année cet homme là
aurait dû démissionner ou le président
de la république hors du le remercier
écart qu'elle soit le déconfinement leur
confinement
les français sont incertitude la plus
totale est évidemment là c'est plus que
perturbant pour le tissu économique pour
le tissu des commerçants politiciens des
stations de ski qui se demandent comment
elles vont pouvoir fonctionner et on
s'achemine vers un tiers des
indépendants qui risquent de mettre la
clé sous la porte et près de la moitié
des restaurateurs
donc c'est absolument énorme c'est une
une une lumineuse faillite de cette
politique sanitaire et qui en plus à une
tentative de dérive sanitaire qui
restreint les libertés publiques des
commerçants de et de tous les français
qui ne dérive inquiétante
est-ce qu'on
d'autant qu'on n'a pas véritablement de
d'étude d'impact sur ce confinement et
et la mortalité du duo qu'ovide il
faudra évidemment attendre j'imagine
pour avoir une étude sérieuse
en attendant vous parliez des commerces
et de la période de noël
qu'attendez-vous mardi du chef de l'état
qu'il dessert à les taux tout en
renforçant les mesures barrières
donc moi je les français ont bien
compris la personne de l'eau tombée
malade donc les principes de bon sens de
se laver les mains et principe de bon
sens de du masque qui quand même à
l'intérieur des bureaux des
établissements fermés la règle
les français sont extrêmement
extrêmement patients extrêmement
discipliné néanmoins devant
l'incohérence des mesures prises mais il
faut que la cette fois le président fixe
un cap
s'ils tiennent et que c'est ce cap soit
compréhensible moi j'attends à ce que la
liberté reviennent pour le travail des
petits commerçants pour le travail de
tous ceux qui vont arriver dans cette
fin d'année et sur une partie de leur
chiffre d'affaires dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure des ddd tation des
stations service qui est des stations
pardonner stations de ski qui génère de
l'emploi aussi pour les pour les plus
jeunes
et là on a pu l'entendre déclarations
complètement surréaliste la semaine
dernière en expliquant qu'on veut les
stations de ski à les poireaux en
recruter mais mais dans quel mais dans
quelles conditions
moi j'attends que effectivement pour
reprendre un terme qui a été très
choquant du du premier ministre qu'on
lâche la bride aux français et
comprennent les français pour des
adultes et pas de convaincre un
infantilisme le bloc est ce que le
gouvernement ne s'est pas trompé de
cible entre guillemets justement on ne
surent protégeant pas les personnes
fragiles il commença à venir un petit
peu sur ce terrain là mais pas
franchement pour l'instant mais est-ce
qu'il faut protéger ceux qui risquent de
mourir tout simplement le rôle de la
grand pays c'est de soigner ceux qui
sont malades
le l'échec c'est l'échec bien sûr de du
dépistage des tests du traçage et des
soins et là malheureusement depuis des
années notre système de santé qui
et donc est défaillant il à cette
épidémie de coville qui n'est pas
d'ennemis qui est en jeu entraîne une
surmortalité mais pas partout dans mon
département a peut-être parce que c'est
un département jeunes à ce donc à ce
jour c'est à dire une dizaine de jours
le préfet la rs départementale ne
déplorait pas plus de morts que l'année
dernière donc là la surmortalité il ya
il ya effectivement des chromos bercot
la saturation des hôpitaux non plus
n'est pas arrivé au bout de ce que
c'était au printemps dernier oui mais là
vous avez pu reprendre les schistes de
des mâles de macron il ya quelques
semaines où il parlait de 400 mille
morts il parlait des taux d'occupation
de 9000 personnes en réanimation
on y est pareil forte heureusement mais
la csn politique de la peur que
président doit absolument arrêter pour
redonner un minimum d'espoir et de
confiance au peuple français en la
capacité de l'état à gérer cette
épidémie qui dieu merci n'est pas une
épidémie qu'on a connu tant de la peste
et du choléra
donc le rôle de l'état c'est d'être en
capacité de soigner les plus fragiles et
soigner la population mais évidemment
les plus fragiles avant tout la cette
épidémie c'est d'épidémie a montré que
les premiers atteints vers les causes de
mort c'était des personnes qui étaient
âgés qui était malade
évidemment après des fragilités
personnels qui peuvent faire qu'un jeune
d'une personne en pleine forme soit
gravement malade là vraisemblablement
l'épidémie où les russes a muté n'est
plus aussi dangereux
donc moi ce que j'attends du président
c'est un cap une espérance et des règles
claires et cohérentes merci beaucoup
sébastien meurant d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce soir sur arte france y au
revoir
et en pleine crise sanitaire l'ouverture
du sommet du g20 aujourd'hui en arabie
saoudite un sommet par visioconférence
chacun depuis son pays avec un menu
chargé centrée sur les conséquences de
la pandémie
un rendez vous planétaire qui devrait
consacrer le grand retour en grâce en
tout cas du prince héritier mohammed ben
salman dont la réputation a été entachée
par le scandale khashoggi ce qui ne sera
pas le cas finalement puisque ce premier
géant du monde arabe entrera dans
l'histoire comme un g20 virtuel auquel a
participé
donald trump également présent à
distance le président russe vladimir
poutine
voyez la correspondance de notre
journaliste à moscou antoine guy roux
vladimir poutine a commencé en
mentionnant rapidement les mesures
adoptées par les autorités russes pour
faire face à cette pandémie qui mesure
sanitaire bien sûr mais aussi économique
citant le chômage massif et de longue
durée comme facteur principal d'une
augmentation de la pauvreté
mais ensuite inscrit sa crise sanitaire
que nous traversons dans un contexte
historique
estimant qu'il s'agit d'une des pires
crises que le monde ait connues depuis
près de 100 ans
l'ampleur des problèmes auxquels le man
et a été confronté en 2020 est
absolument sans précédent
l'épidémie de colons à béruges et le
confinement généralisée et le gel d'une
partie de l'activité de l'activité
économique a suscité des transformations
majeures et des problèmes que l'économie
mondiale n'avait jamais connu depuis la
grande dépression
le président russe a ensuite souligné
l'importance de l'économie américaine en
disant qu'il ne pourrait y avoir une
reprise durable sans le rétablissement
de l'économie des états unis
enfin de la lire poutine évoqué des
pistes de sortie de crise avec en
premier lieu bien évidemment les vaccins
contre la copie 19 et les vaccins russe
en particulier à ce titre tout comme
antonio vous dire s il souhaite que ces
vaccins soit accessible ou plus grand
nous notre pays la russie est tout à
fait prête à participer à ces travaux
d'élaboration de mc5 notamment notre
vaccin foot ligue et qui a été le
premier à mettre à être mis sur le
marché dans le monde et c'est pareil à
nouveau subir ce qui a été mis au point
un deuxième vaccin 3e et sur le plein
point d'être validé actuellement donc
nous avons mis toutes les ressources
possibles ici parce que notre objectif
commun est d'assurer pour l'ensemble de
la population de la terre une protection
sûre et fiable pour conclure 20-10 mire
poutine a noté des initiatives du java
pour relancer l'économie et a rappelé
toute l'importance compte à ses yeux les
grandes institutions internationales des
institutions comme le g20 ou encore les
nations unies et c'est de cette façon en
améliorant encore davantage les
mécanismes de coopération internationale
que pourront je cite être relever les
défis qui se présentent aujourd'hui le
retour de blaise compaore au centre de
l'élection présidentielle au burkina
faso demain les électeurs devront
choisir un chef de l'état et les députés
de l'assemblée nationale
la plupart des partis de l'opposition
sont favorables au retour de l'ancien
président qui est toujours en exil en
côte d'ivoire des élections qui
pourraient bien être entravée par une
partie du territoire sur une partie du
territoire à cause de l'insécurité est
liée au terrorisme islamiste parmi les
13 candidats en lice il y a le président
sortant roch marc christian kaboré qui
brigue un deuxième mandat
julien duroux roch marc christian kaboré
avait de grandes ambitions pour le
développement du burkina faso hauteur de
grandes réalisations d'infrastructures
tels que la centrale solaire de zagtouli
ou encore l'échangeur routier de la
capitale ouagadougou le président
sortant n'a pourtant pas été aidés
héritier d'une situation sécuritaire
préoccupante dû à de nombreuses attaques
djihadistes kaboré n'a pas pu éviter une
crise économique lors de son mandat
certains chiffres annoncés notamment
ceux du développement du pays aurait été
très surestimée mais s'il veut être
réélu le président sortant devra à
nouveau battre le chef de file de
l'opposition
zéphirin diabré comme une sensation de
déjà vu puisque l'élection
présidentielle de 2015 avait déjà opposé
ces deux candidats diabré escompte cette
fois ci remporté ce scrutin après avoir
été battu à sa grande surprise
lui qui avait mené la révolte qui a
abouti sur la destitution de l'ancien
président blaise compaore le pose en
président sortant n'a d'ailleurs pas
mâché ses mots sur le bilan du mandat de
kaboré ce régime est née d'une
insurrection et cette insurrection a eu
lieu parce qu'on dénonçait la mauvaise
gouvernance
donc ça fend le coeur des burkinabè que
ce même régime n'accorde pas une grande
attention à la lutte contre la
corruption et qu'au contraire il soit en
agent de la corruption
un autre candidat veut lui aussi
postuler en tant que chef de file de
l'opposition nouveau visage du congrès
pour la démocratie et le progrès eddie
komboïgo se présente comme adversaire
direct de kaboré cet expert comptable de
54 ans compte bien faire revenir au
premier plan un parti qui a gouverné le
pays durant 27 ans jusqu'à l'éviction de
compaore en 2014 et pour cette élection
eddie komboïgo a des arguments de taille
[Musique]
cinq ans durant trois ministres de la
défense trois ministres de la sécurité
et on continue d'abattre nos populations
je ne peux pas accepter cela nous allons
relancer l'économie à partir de
l'industrie agroalimentaire de
l'industrie minière et nous allons
organiser l'ensemble des orpailleurs
nous allons en faire des semis
industriels qui vont employer nos jeunes
parmi les 13 candidats en lice y élit
monique cam est la seule femme pour
cette élection celle pour surnomme la
yennenga de l'éducation en référence à
une princesse du royaume de dagong bas
se présente sous les couleurs du
mouvement pour la renaissance pour sa
première candidature
la chef d'entreprise vont en cette
élection l'opportunité d'améliorer
l'éducation qui est selon elle la clé du
développement durable burkinabé un
élément qu'elle met d'ailleurs en avant
dans un de ses slogans de campagne par
l'éducation
un autre burkina faso est possible et
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve dans 30
minutes rester avec nous
et
[Musique]
on l'a vu en doc sur le continent en
france amazon est sous le feu des
critiques accusée notamment de
concurrence est déloyale quand on
interdit tous les commerces de
fonctionner faut pas s'étonner que les
gens se tournent vers amazon des zones
secrètes
il serait aussi en position dominante en
décembre l'état devrait prélever à 3% du
chiffre d'affaires réalisé en france
aujourd'hui on sait